thank you so much both of you professor
Clark I was curious do you think there's
a danger and trying to delusional eyes
the International Criminal Court and
other international bodies of justice
and that the idea but it might give more
power to criminal criminal governments
and I was curious that your Uganda
example which was was very brief where
in that case I would say that I would
support the International Criminal
Court's work and that the Ugandan
government itself many people think has
been complicit with the Lawrence
libration our lord's resistance movement
in northern Uganda and has you know if
not channel funds then at least you know
ignored some of their activities over
the last couple of decades so it
concerns me if we you know throw these
international justice bodies out the
window and we're assuming that you know
some local or state processes are
legitimate and I think in the nigeria
case not in the case in particular but
when most people I know who are Nigerian
or have experience in Nigeria would not
put their full faith in the local
justice bodies and so would want some
kind of either a back-and-forth or at
least some relationship outside of
Nigeria to help ensure that the local
processes are are with integrity okay so
that's a loaded question in many ways no
quite political one but I I welcome it
this is what this is what we do here I
welcome it so is there a danger to 2d
legitimize how do I respond to that
without being defensive I'm not delegate
amaizing I'm engaging in critical
engagement and in fact one of the things
that I say at the beginning of the book
and in the beginning of the many
articles is is that i'm not writing
against human rights I simply think we
can do it better much better and I think
the example around the mobilization of
feminist with the amino the wild sophia
has
any case is an example of that the need
to work much more effectively to
communicate with those for which we
claim we're healthy what about the
communication as basic as that what that
you know what about collaboration that
involves finding out what one needs and
how to deploy forces to to their aid so
to engage critically isn't 2d legitimize
that's the response to the first I think
that that's the important for us to to
reckon with the second has to do with
local processes I actually I don't think
that that's the way to go about making
human right systems better to to simply
be skeptical about local justice systems
in fact the Nigerian mechanism worked
effectively Amina Llewellyn Sofia did
not die and although what we saw I mean
many of us read these Internet postings
and took from that that after the the
court holding of the death by stoning
judgment she was immediately going to be
stoned either Amina or Sofia which
wasn't the case at all Nigeria has a
quite complex legal system the last of
which is the the Supreme Court
constitutional and so there are steps
just as there are in the u.s.
adjudication and and and so I think that
the important the importance here is to
to educate ourselves on what these
fundamental steps are within these local
processes and to to participate or look
at the ways in which people are working
on capacity building in a range of
regions and and work with them so when
you bring up the Uganda case I have a
couple of chapters on Uganda it's it's
certainly for those of us who write
about and are interested in
international criminal law the Uganda
case was the first case before the court
and and and continues to be or at least
wasn't the first case but it was the
first case for which the first moment in
which arrest warrants were
released and they have not succeeded of
course and that you know the Warlord's
are still at large but they're there a
lot of incompatibilities and it's in
uganda's justice system which makes even
the ICC's jurisdiction questionable and
what is needed I think in the Ugandan
case isn't simply to embrace the ICC
wholeheartedly it's to think
fundamentally about the ways in which
the Ugandan capacity needs to be rebuilt
because beyond the ICC adjudicatory
measures of you know taking on three or
four warlords then what happens do we
simply go to international institutions
or multilateral institutions each time
there's a problem no I think to think
long term is to think about the
strengthening the capacities thinking
about rewriting or even amending laws
that are in conflict with the statutes
and treaties that are being signed by
these countries and so there's a lot of
infrastructural work that needs to be
done and I think that that's the that's
where the rolling up the sleeves and
getting active with collaborative work
those who are working with NGOs and
others this is the kind of work that
that needs to be done in this regard
just a friendly amendment to that this
is a not a new question about
sovereignty and jurisdiction over crime
with an over arching body we've dealt
with that very same question in the 18th
century we're trying to figure out the
division between federal and state
authority over the punishment of crime
and and the solution that was ultimately
reached in the American context was to
leave sovereignty over criminal law
enforcement at the local level at the
state level but to put in place a series
of procedural human rights safeguards
articulated clearly in the 4th through
8th amendment bill of rights and then
amplified further in the 14th amendment
due process and equal protection clauses
all of which are simply to say the
mechanisms at the local level can
continue in place we will respect the
sovereignty that the individual states
have even if they differ in part in the
way that they implement
basic understandings of criminal justice
but will have certain overarching
non-negotiables in human rights
procedural terms that cannot be trusted
and over time that negotiation over two
and a half century to century plus
period has been there are certain things
that the states don't do well we've
created bodies of federal criminal law
to overlay the individual state laws and
we have a body of federal crimes now
that get enforced in the federal courts
and in many ways I think what we're
going to see in the 21st century is a
bit of the same exercise at the National
at the international level individual
sovereign nation states are going to be
have they're going to have basic
jurisdiction over criminal matters
they're going to be a set of human
rights constraints imposed by their own
local state constitutions and the
international treaties that they
ratified and then the question is going
to be whether there are overarching
bodies in the ICC or some of its
eventual progeny that are going to
provide oversight and ultimate appellate
authority to ensure that local processes
for sovereign purposes don't trespass
fundamental universal human rights
cannot be trusted that's an interesting
historical analogy